we are currently in Al AA Hospital in
the middle area of in the Gaza City and
since the morning the ambulances did not
stop bringing and transferring killed
bodies and injuries from different areas
across the middle area where yesterday
was a deadly night where the artillery
shelling did not stop shelling in the
middle area let's walk a little bit in
the hospital and let's show you how
these injured patients are living
they're crowded they have no space they
have no beds people are currently laying
down on the floor where every patient
has zero
privacy people are are not only taking
and seeking this hospital as a refuge
but it's
also a place where people are receiving
treatment where as the Israeli forces
started its ground invasion
most of the doctors in the hospital
evacuated fearing the same scenario that
happened in the AL shifa
hospital this is the scene right now
where as you see it's very crowded a lot
of injuries entered the hospital since
the morning we see children we see women
we see men and it's it's it's it's it's
more than the capacity of the hospital
where alpal hospital it's one of the
only hospitals still facilitating in uh
the Central
Area most of the doctors as you
see are trying their best to all of
these
injuries it's I smell blood
everywhere I hear The Echoes of people
being hurt today Palestinians in the
middle area are evacuating and we see
people taking their ts from the
surroundings of the hospital going to ra
and everyone is leaving the to raah
because they are fearing that the
Israeli forces are going to uh uh
surround and are going to invade Al AA
hospital just like they did with two
hospitals at least two hospitals in the
north we're talking about alcha hospital
and the Indonesian Hospital hospital and
everyone is scared everyone fears a
grand Invasion and for 93 days people
are still trapped under the rubble
people are still being killed and more
people are being homeless this isind
Al
Hospital make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer